hello everybody and welcome to part 15
of let's play amnesia the Dark Descent
I am markiplier and I will be taking you
through this as we know one of the
monsters finally landed a sucker punch
you know if they stab me in the back as
I was running away but they still stab
me in the back and that's cheap
who's there lucky I don't have my
sledgehammer
where are you good punch in your face
yeah you didn't want none of this anyway
way too strong for you
you're just lucky my sledgehammer
mysteriously went right through your
body but whatever yep I'm good yeah I'm
so good Oh yep
aha BAM gay man huh yeah that'll be
useful a cow
you lucky he stick meat in cow go me go
Oh
yeah Oh
oh really who comes up with this was
this really a thing
ah all right up I see it glowy ha ha
mine oh right I think that's all of them
I don't know I have no idea is that six
pieces yeah whatever okay I'm outta here
just try to stop me
he's trying to stop me
don't try to stop me uh-huh
whoa awesome
Oh Tom yeah but he didn't see me or else
he would have run away like a little
girl I see you go get out of here fat
you ever
I'll stop for you break or you get tired
turn around
good attic here yep yeah blood of a
pansy
which way you going which way you go so
I know behind you uppercut solar plexus
and away I go
got nothing on this
oh yeah
right to the door cuz I'm that good yeah
uh-huh
yep okay that's perfectly stairs again
more exercise yep yep yep okay back to
the nave okay I got your orb old man
oh shut up on a little you found my
aggression there's a toy yeah it's still
a child
listen counter Alexander is working on
opening and take a kid or two us alone
it's that he wants to go oh that's
lovely if you could put your handler
side let you open some fort open or you
take your revenge a haunted me pass
together okay please find XIII gets it
has a chronic liar disguise okay and do
so be flowing the cells of for superior
keeping you from inner sanctum will only
be bleached for short time unless
everything is taken care of our meetings
are all alright you won't be able to say
ah would that be too bad
where do I go I don't even know uh was
one of the ingredients three ingredients
now that's very descriptive tonic made a
paralyzer vit a and tamper poison I got
the fungi yeah got agonize human
victim's blood
ooh you tamper uh tamp jurors re-secure
water-dwelling Carrick farewell is that
the water oh I know I know that I know
that thing that thing I know I um
where's uh I know this I know I know
this cuz it's right here yeah gimme
yours blood or whatever I'm getting ah
give it to me
sorry about that I've been yelling all
day in my computer so been kind of hard
on my throat nothing gave me nothing
ah all you want to me oh that's gonna be
mommy but I'll give it to you
oh yeah I got a big one come on up yeah
oh yeah come on get back here
oh come up here with a but it can't go
anymore yeah I got some gimme gimme
Oh what the hell remains I'm such a
thing so when they needed alright what
was the other thing uh fit a I need
blood any blood oh god shut up you got
your food well there were plenty of
humans tortured in agony I'm sure I'll
be able to find some
see
right hany meenie miney moe catch I'm
going through this see that one was and
see all the weight okay no blood that
was this oh the crucible might be pull
it all saw this was the song
gimme your blood
good thing I lit these candles like the
responsible tin tinderbox user I am Oh
blood giving all right cool ah I still
have this
rope rope is good plenty of rope here
rope broke
string Frank string huh
easy is that good sploosh yep I got that
it's all good
is that everything three ingredients
blah blah blah three one two three uh
yep okay all right I'm good where the
hell do is under them oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah thank you
the thing the thing was the place
okay getting through this I'm getting
through I smell a final confrontation
coming up I see that also all pieces you
know I don't have no right but yeah I
got what you needed
look if you could find any uh uh right
I'll make your stupid tonic chancel good
I wanted to get back here need to get
back to that guy you know didn't scare
me or nothin he just I need to punch him
in the face I punched everyone to face
so far just need to finish with them
shut up Daniel don't be scared come on
out us just oh [ __ ] I'm gonna get again
I can go ah hood what what what what ah
damn it
yeah
uhh
uh-oh okay that makes sense I guess yeah
go away ugly guy here I hate you
whatever
you had me worried quite frankly I'm not
sure what to do with you
a shudder I hold no grudge against you
dang or sure you do we are so very much
the same you and I Yeah right
do you really drink from your teachers
yeah
what's it to you it does explain so much
of your behavior you never did finish
what you set out to do
oh yeah whatever you talked about
redemption how you would face the old
shadow and save our work and yeah
whatever I will grant you another chance
to redeem yourself you can wait here and
stop the shadow this guy Daniel really
is a dick friend if he promised that and
did follow through and now wants to kill
ah
now let's to kill a good Alexandre he's
kind of a douche alright bucket go
bucket her keep her remove my hand by
blood huh oh it's so heavy
oh come here come on move you with a bed
ha right
let me out
I don't belong here I didn't do it oh oh
oh ah ah yes oh yeah oh yeah come here
BAM giggle new girl gay ah kaboom
well that is helpful
oh there we go ah okay all right what do
I do
come on come on come on
ah okay I see it
do I move it the
yeah get what uh I heard it groan OH
oh [ __ ] there cuz yeah all right
freedom shut up
gimme what you got come on gimme gimme
oh nothing
well that's useful not note little F to
say unfortunate first arrive buried
inside a tomb yeah it seems like it I
key down pipes Oh key down pipes yep
alright key down a pipe 1 pipe boil
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
ah oh what the hell
Oh what's with the naked guys uh yeah ah
I guess not that there's anything wrong
with naked guys if you appreciate that
door thing but did it I'd rather they
not be dead you know
you know what I mean all right
you probably don't know I could figure
this
water bucket give me water water water
why
all right give me back my water oh no
something's caught on the end nope just
water
gimme gimme all right
pipes ding dong ding dong ding dong ding
dong pipe
Oh aha give me a mega oh all right
logical keep watching I was gonna throw
a rock in it what that works to a little
more elegant google it
okay the key not so bad so much for jail
haha shut up okay that's a little more
violent
oh god is it chasing me oh [ __ ] me oh
god oh [ __ ] me
Oh get out of here good you're chasing
me isn't it chase me I don't know
stop shaking oh [ __ ] it is Oh God
all right right oh no now right now
right laughs ah right this isn't so bad
bring it on you I'm tough go away I'm
not water hot water hot water what a bad
one of that uh water bad and right there
odd right there head right there water
man Wonderman Wonderman
butter matter by the way there no out of
it a little bit out of it okay all right
yeah yeah look too fast for you what's
going on what's going on yeah nothing
nothing yeah you got nothing oh what's
that oh that don't look so bad okay
oh [ __ ]
ah okay I was pretty intense I like that
I like that a lot I actually have to war
I actually have to pause it here thank
you guys so much for watching
stick around and I will see you for part
16 of let's play amnesia the Dark
Descent goodbye